hello and welcome to the anthropos scine
reviewed a podcast where we review
different facets of the human centered
planet on a five-star
scale today in this podcast's first
everever one review episode I'll be
reviewing Al Lang z a song that is today
most associated with New Year's
Eve I find it fascinating that in a
world we're so much is so new we welcome
new years's by singing a very old
song the chorus starts out for all
langine my Joe for all Lang Zine I'll
take a cup of kindness yet for Al Lang
Z Joe is a Scots word that can be
straightforwardly translated to Deer but
Al Lang Zion is more complicated ated it
literally means something like old long
since but it's idiomatically similar to
the old times we have a phrase in
English somewhat similar to for old
langine the phrase is For Old Times Sake
here's a bit of my old long
[Music]
sense in the summer of 2001 the writer
Amy Krauss Rosenthal emailed booklist
magazine to inquire about a review at
the time I was working for booklist as a
publishing assistant most of my job was
data entry but I also answered many of
the low priority emails that came in so
I responded to Amy with an update on the
status of the review and I also
mentioned that on a personal note I had
loved her Zen like column in might
magazine I told her I often thought
about one bit she'd written which
went every time I'm flying and the
captain announces the beginning of our
descent the same thing goes through my
mind while we're still pretty high above
the city I'll think if the plane went
down now we would definitely not be okay
A bit lower and no we still wouldn't be
okay but as we get real close to the
ground I'll relax okay we're low enough
now if it crashed now we might be okay
she wrote me back the next day and asked
if I was a writer and I said I was
trying to be and she asked if I had
anything that was 2 minutes long that
might work on the
radio we don't really know when Al Lang
Zine was written the first verse goes
should old acquaintance be forgot and
never brought to mind should old
acquaintance be forgot and Old Lang Zine
versions of that date back at least 400
years but we owe the current song to The
Great Scottish poet Robert Burns in
December of 1788 he wrote to his friend
Francis Dunlop is not the scotch phrase
Al langine exceedingly expressive
there's an old song In Tune which has
often thrilled through my soul light be
the turf on the breast of the heaven
inspired poet who composed this glorious
fragment and on the back of the letter
Burns wrote the first known draft of Al
Lang Zine at least three of the verses
were probably his own although he would
later say of the song that he quote took
it down from an old
man part of what makes dating various
Lines within the song Difficult is the
song's eternality it's about drinking
together and remembering old times and
almost every idea within it from Picking
Daisies to wandering through fields to
toasting old friends over a beer could
have been written 500 a th000 or even
3,000 years ago it's also a rousing Ode
to splitting the check incidentally with
part of the second verse going and
surely you'll buy your pint cup and
surely I'll buy mine but mostly the song
is just an Unapologetic celebration of
the good old days and of looking back
upon
them I guess I should tell you that Amy
is dead otherwise her death within this
review might seem like some kind of
narrative device which I don't want so
okay she is dead the rare present tense
sentence that once it becomes true stays
true
forever but we aren't there yet we were
still still in the past I think she
asked me if I had anything for the radio
and I sent her three little essays and
she liked one of them and asked me to
come in and record it for her show on
Chicago's public radio station
WBEZ in the broadcast you could hear the
nerves in my voice it was the first time
I'd ever reached such a large audience
after that Amy invited me to be on her
show more often and within a year I was
recording frequent commentaries for w be
e and then for nprs all things
considered sometimes Amy took me out to
lunch she was everything I wanted to be
happily married a committed and loving
parent and a successful writer she was
also incredibly good at gift giving at
our first lunch I told her that when I
moved to Chicago my mom asked me to
carry $40 with me in my left pants
pocket whenever I went outside
so I would have something to give anyone
who might want to mug me and I told Amy
that I still always kept 40 bucks in my
left pocket and that I tried never to
spend my mugging money except in cases
of real
need the next time we met Amy surprised
me with two gifts one was a money clip
engraved with my initials jmg and the
other was a money clip engraved with mm
mugging money
in April of 2002 Amy convened some of
her writer and musician friends for an
event at the chopan theater in Chicago
called writer block party she asked me
to read for it and I did and people
laughed at my dumb jokes and Amy hired
someone to walk around the theater
giving everyone compliments and the
compliment said they liked my shoes
which were these brand new Adidas
sneakers and that is why I have worn ad
sneakers almost every day for the last
years Robert Burns originally had a
different tune in mind for Al langine
than the one most of us know and
although he himself realized the air was
quote mediocre you will still sometimes
hear that original Arrangement it is
used for example in the noted 2008 film
sex in the city but the melody most of
us know first appeared in
1799 in George Thompson's select songs
of Scotland by then Robert Burns was
gone he was only 37 when he died of a
heart condition possibly exacerbated by
his habit of raising many a pint glass
to Old
acquaintances in his last letter he
wrote to Francis Dunlop an illness which
has long hung about me in all
probability will speedily send me beyond
that born whence no traveler
[Music]
returns but the song was just getting
started within decades it became a
popular part of New Year's Eve
celebrations in Scotland a holiday known
as hog Manet that can trace its history
back to Winter Solstice rituals by 1818
Beethoven had written an arrangement of
it and it was beginning to travel
throughout Europe and the
English-speaking world today Al Lang
Zine is often played at Japanese
department stores just before they close
between 1945 and 1948 the tune was used
in South Korea's national anthem in the
Netherlands its Melody inspired one of
the country's most famous football
chants and it's a staple of film
soundtracks from Charlie chaplain's 1925
movie The Gold Rush to its a Wonderful
Life in
1946 to minions in
2015 I think Al langine is popular in
Hollywood not just because it's in the
the public domain and therefore cheap
but also because it's the rare song that
is genuinely wistful it acknowledges
human longing without romanticizing it
and it captures how each new year is a
product of all the old ones when I sing
Al langine on New Year's Eve I forget
the words like everyone does until I get
to the fourth verse which I do have
memorized we two have paddled in the
stream from Morning Sun till dine but
Seas between us broad have roared since
Al
langine and I think about the many broad
seas that have roared between me and the
past Seas of neglect Seas of time Seas
of death I'll never speak again to many
of the people who loved me into this
moment just as you you will never speak
to many of the people who loved you into
your
now and so we raise a glass to them and
hope that perhaps somewhere they are
raising a glass to
us in her strange and beautiful
interactive Memoir textbook Amy Krauss
Rosenthal Amy wrote If one is generously
contra Ed 80 years that amounts to
29,2019 there has to be an exact number
let's just say it's
12,395 absolutely that is a lot but it
is not infinite and anything less than
infinite seems too measly a number and
is not
satisfactory in her writing Amy often
sought to reconcile the infinite nature
of Consciousness and love and yearning
with the finite nature of the universe
and all that inhabits
it toward the end of textbook she wrote
a multiple choice question in the alley
there is a bright pink flower peeking
out through the asphalt a it looks like
futility B it looks like
hope for me at least Al langang Zine
captures exactly what it feels like to
see a bright pink flower peeking out
through the asphalt and how it feels to
know that you have
12,395 times to look at a
[Music]
tree in 2005 Amy published a memoir in
the form of an encyclopedia called
Encyclopedia of an ordinary life that
book ends I was here you see I
was another sentence that once it
becomes true never stops being
true that book came out just a few
months before my first novel Looking for
Alaska soon thereafter my wife Sarah got
into graduate school at Colombia and so
we moved to New York Amy and I stayed in
touch and collaborated occasionally over
the next decade I played a bit part in
an experience she curated for hundreds
of people on August 8th 2008 in
Chicago's Millennium Park but it was
never again like it had been in those
early
days she found out she had cancer not
long after finishing textbook Amy cross
Rosenthal and she called me she knew
that in the years after the Fault in Our
Stars was published I'd come to know
many young people who were Gravely ill
and she wanted to know if I had advice
for her I told her what I think is true
that love survives death but she wanted
to know how young people react to death
how her kids would she wanted to know if
her kids and her husband would be okay
or how she could make it okay for them
and that ripped me up although I'm
usually quite comfortable talking with
sick people with my friend I found
myself stumbling over words overwhelmed
with my own sadness and
worry they won't be okay of course but
they will go on and the love you poured
into them will go on that's what I
should have said but what I actually
said while crying was how can this be
happening you do so much
[Music]
yoga in my experience dying people often
have wonderful stories of the horrible
things that healthy people say to them
but I've never heard of anybody saying
anything close to as stupid as you do so
much
yoga I hope that Amy got some narrative
mileage out of me saying something so
profoundly idiotic in her hour of need
but I also know I failed her after she
was there for me so many times I know
she forgives me but still I desperately
wish I could have said something
useful or perhaps not said anything at
all when people we love are suffering we
want to make it better but sometimes
times often in fact you can't make it
better I'm reminded of something my
supervisor said to me when I was a
student chaplain at a children's
hospital don't just do something stand
there Al Lang Zion was a popular song in
World War I versions of it were sung in
trenches not just by British soldiers
but by French and German and Austrian
ones as well and the song even played a
small role in one of the strangest and
most beautiful moments in world history
the Christmas Truce of
1914 on Christmas Eve that year in part
of the war's Western Front in what is
now Belgium around 100,000 British and
German soldiers emerged from their
trenches and met each other in the
so-called no man's land between their
front lines one 19-year-old old British
soldier wrote his mother yesterday the
British and Germans met and shook hands
in the ground between the trenches and
exchanged
souvenirs marvelous isn't it a German
soldier remembered that a British solder
quote brought a soccer ball from their
trenches and pretty soon a lively game
ensued how marvelously wonderful yet how
strange it was Elsewhere on the front
captain sir Edward Hulse recalled a
Christmas singalong that quote ended up
with Al Lang Zion which we all English
Scots Irish prussians venberg Etc joined
in it was absolutely astounding and if I
had seen it on cinematograph film I
should have sworn it was
faked hul who was 25 years old at the
time would be killed on the Western
Front less than 4 months later at least
17 million people would die as a direct
result of the war more than half the
current population of
Canada by Christmas of 196 soldiers
didn't want trues the devastating losses
of the war and the growing use of poison
gas had embittered the
combatants but many also had no idea why
they were fighting and dying for tiny
patches of ground so far from home and
in the British trenches soldiers began
to sing the tune of Al Lang Zine with
different words we're here because we're
here because we're here because we're
here here was a world without wise where
life was meaninglessness all the way
down modernity had come to war and the
rest of Life the art critic Robert
Hughes once referred to the quote
peculiarly modernist hell of
repetition and the trenches of World War
I were hell
indeed although she was a playful and
optimistic writer Amy was not deluded
about the nature of suffering or about
its centrality in human life her work
whether picture book or Memoir always
find finds a way to acknowledge misery
without giving into it one of the last
lines she ever wrote was death may be
knocking on my door but I'm not getting
out of this glorious bath to answer
it in her public appearances Amy would
sometimes use that recursive lament of
British soldiers and transform it
without ever changing the tune or the
words she would ask an audience to sing
that song with her we're here because
we're here because we're here because
we're
here and although it is of course a
profoundly nihilistic song written about
the modernist hell of repetition singing
that song with Amy I could always see
the Hope in it it became a statement
that we are here meaning that we are
together and not alone and it's also a
statement that we are that we exist and
it's a statement that we are here that a
series of astonishing
unlikelihood has made us possible and
hear possible we might never know why we
are here but we can still Proclaim in
hope that we are here I don't think such
hope is foolish or idealistic or
misguided I believe that hope is for
lack of a better word
true we live in hope that life will get
better and more importantly that it will
go on that Love Will Survive even though
we will not as Emily Dickinson put it
hope is the thing with feathers that
perches in the soul and sings the tune
without the words and never stops at
all and we are here because we are here
because we're here because we're
here sing it with me wherever you are
think of those across the broad and
roaring seas and sing with me you won't
be more off tune than I
am we're here because we're here because
we're here because we're
here we're here because we're here
because we're
here because we're
here I give all the line five
stars